&gt;&gt; Manipulating this in the ways that we've practiced gives us m is greater than
or equal to 333 and 1 3rd. Let's look at this on a number line. So, m can be
anything to the right of, or including, 333 and a third. But wait, what are we
talking about anyway? What was m equal to? M is equal to the number of deluxe
wipers sold. Now, you can't sell a third of a wiper set, so that means we're
going to have to make m into a whole number. Now, if we make it 333, then we
won't quite make it to our $20,000 profit level. So, that mean that we're going
to have to round up. M has to be greater than or equal to 334 wipers. Well, I'm
going to leave our number line looking just like this, because these would be
about in the same place. You can just imagine that our bracket has shifted
slightly to the right. What we want is the minimum possible value for m, so the
smallest value in this range of possible solutions. That, of course, is going to
be just this endpoint solution, 334 exactly. So we want m equals 334.